starmedia his lawyer Michael at vanetti
has spent weeks on television
looks more like pro wrestling than
Waring but whatever you decide mr. Trump
will not serve out his term no way no
how lawyers don't normally do talk shows
I'm not your normal lawyer I guess every
statement that I've made every
prediction in this case thus far Don
Lemon has come true the only out that
the president will have the only out
will be to resign the office this is not
a publicity stunt I mean this is serious
business we're gonna continue to use the
media I think we've used it with great
success this whole thing is unbelievable
Mark's dad is an author and columnist he
joins us tonight mark I'm still in the
quest to get my one question answered
which is this crime that supposedly took
place who's the victim of it
I would I would have to disagree I think
with Richard slightly because if anybody
is it's the president the only crime
that's going on here is is blackmail
this this this woman and Trump engaged
in an act that I would not have wanted
to engage in with her but it was
consensual and and she threatened to
talk about it they signed a
nondisclosure agreement for 130 grand
one of the stupid things about
non-disclosure agreements is that if one
party breaks it then in order to
demonstrate that they breach the
non-disclosure agreement you have to
disclose it yourself so they're fairly
pointless and stupid things it's that in
fact this this woman well they mean that
I mean that as a semi serious point here
Tucker because this this story is a lot
of things but it's not a crime and when
you look at this guy Evan Eddie going on
talk shows he's brilliant as a kite he
plays a good sleazy bum shyster lawyer
on TV but he doesn't actually have a
case in the courtroom because the only
people who are committing any crime here
are the two shakedown artists which is
stormy and her lawyer
have you heard anybody oh thank you no I
I don't have strong feelings about any
part of this case and that's why it took
me until yesterday to realize wait a
second why is nobody saying that it's
just such an obvious point she got a
hundred and thirty grand why does that
make her a hero that doesn't seem like
the kind of behavior that we would be in
favor of well one of the the she's she's
an aging porn star which is not a good
thing to be I I haven't seen any of her
motion picture role Nezzer
but but on Saturday Night Live when she
delivered that line that porn stars are
known for their acting she actually
delivered it totally woodenly so that
even by porn star standards she seemed
to be a fairly wooden actress and she
she yes it is and she needs evidently
she needs the body but to go back to
what you were talking about with Richard
my my view of Trump is that people chose
him in the nominating process because he
done everything Mitt Romney was the
worst guy on the planet because he gave
a wedgie to a kid in grade 3 if you
recall and he put a dog in his roof and
drove the dog to Canada and people pick
Trump this time because they know that
if he ever drove a dr. Canada he'd give
him a wedgie every half mile up i-95 so
people assume that Trump has done
everything and it's baked in the cake so
maybe the election wasn't really a
referendum on Trump's personal way for
his moral standing maybe there were
other issues that voters are trying to
get our attention on get us to pay
attention to and we're not yeah I think
that I think if you live in a
broken-down town where the mills closed
and your daughter's got nothing to do
except the night shift at the quickie
crap and she's dating a heroin dealer
you're not actually you're not actually
voting for Trump because he's the
perfect gentleman you're voting for
Trump because everything else you voted
for in the last 20 years has failed you
that is absolutely right and it leads
seamlessly in return our next segment
because we really are gonna continue
trying to talk about the issues that
this is all about you know and it's not
stormy anyway thank you Mark
great to see you thanks a lot Tucker